hi there today we're looking at Excel
net generalized auto regressive
pre-training for language understanding
by Jill and yang and other people from
Carnegie Mellon University as well as
Google brain so this is kind of a the
elephant in the room currently as Excel
net is the first model to beat Bert
which was the previous state of the art
and a lot of NLP tasks to be burped at a
lot of these same NLP tasks so the chief
state of the art result on 18 of of 20
tasks I believe maybe they test one they
outperform Bert on 20 the chief state of
the art on 18 including things asked
question answering natural language
inference sentiment analysis and so on
so those are kind of remarkable results
and even more remarkable is that the
architecture of the network is actually
very very similar to Bert the kind of
new introduction is a a pre-training a
different free training procedure and
we'll look into that
so let's actually jump into their main
points straight away what they go into
is there are two kinds of currently used
pre training methods for these NLP test
and both or can be understood as kind of
a language modeling one
so language modeling for those you don't
know is predict the next word in a
sequence so if I give you the sequence
here unsupervised representation
learning has been and then ask you
what's next and then you're supposed to
say highly right those language modeling
in in a nutshell so what they what they
differentiate are two kinds of language
modeling the first one they say is order
aggressive language modeling
now what auto regressive language
modeling does is exactly what we've
looked at I give you unsupervised
learning has been you were supposed to
predict highly and then in the next step
I give you unsupervised representation
learning has been highly and you're
supposed to predict success
and so on so in the next step I'm gonna
give you the entire sentence up until
here and you're supposed to do predict
in autoregressive because each token can
look at the kind of previous ones in the
in the sequence so when you sorry you
can't see that when you predict when you
predict you you can always kind of order
aggressively look at what the previous
ones were when including what you've
previously predicted of course during
training this is a teacher first as I
said so you put the actual words there
this is auto regressive modeling in
contrast to what they call Auto encoding
and Auto encoding is what birth does and
this is the following so in contrast to
that let's say I have the same sequence
unsupervised representation learning has
been highly successful in the domain of
yeah something and then I say okay I
give you the sequence but I am going to
delete this and this right and now I ask
you to predict these two right so you
can see the the task is slightly
different as you now have access to all
of the sequence basically except the
ones that you are asked to predict but
you're you kind of asked to predict yet
them not in any order but you're asked
to predict them at the same time
basically so at the same time you're
you're asked to predict this word and
this word and so the first kind of this
Auto regressive language modeling has
been used by transformer models until
birth and then basically bert really
pushed this auto encoding language model
pre-training which made it so successful
and now this paper excel net wants to
like combine the best of both of them
and in order to understand what's the
best of both of them so what's good at
birth we've already seen it can actually
draw information from all of the context
of the words it's trying to predict but
what is the kind of pitfall of birth and
they they actually put this really
nicely in an example they give way
further down where they say comparison
to but I don't know why that is not like
also in the introduction but here they
have the sentence New York is a city
right New York is a city this one and
you're asked to predict these two words
and if you now compare birth to what xl9
does if so the context is is a city and
you're asked to predict New York what
birth does is it simply masks out the
two words and says here please fill in
these two words now this translates to
the kind of objective being separated in
the two words such that the prediction
of York here is completely independent
of the prediction of new so if you know
of any other city that is made of two
words for example San Francisco or Los
Angeles then these would be as valid and
any mixture would be as valid so you
might there might end up with laws York
is a city and that would be perfectly
fine for birth because while it's
predicting loss is a perfectly fine
prediction for the first word of a
two-word City and York is a perfectly
fine prediction for the last word of a
two-word City right so these are the
kind of mistakes that bird can get into
by not being order aggressive by
basically predicting all of these tokens
at the same time independently of each
other whereas x-l net what they will do
is we specify an order let's say okay
first I will predict the word noon for
the first word new something is a city
and then when I predict York I will
actually take into account the
I previously have predicted the word new
so um that's the main advantage at that
autoregressive training has over Auto
encoding now what are the pitfalls the
pitfalls or if you have this this
sentence let's look at it I'll write it
down
New York is a city right if you have
this sentence and let's say yeah
actually you're not you're not asked to
predict you and your crew you're asked
to predict the word a here a right
you're asked to predict that in order
regressive style or a city it's a better
example the two words I said in order
regressive style if you predict the word
a you can only ever look at what comes
before hand whereas if Bert were to
predict a just the word a it would be
able to look at all of it
that's not predict City so you see the
kind of auto regressive model is bound
to the order of the of the factorization
of the sentence that's right it's bound
to the order in which it has to predict
the tokens so here if it's predicting a
you can only look at stuff that comes
before it because it needs to do it in
order right once it gets to city you can
actually look at the entire sentence
here but um before that it only ever has
partial information about the about the
context so actually it wouldn't be much
better if I had said we're trying to
predict these two words is and a right
and once I predict so so Bert would
actually have access to the word City
here whereas the auto regressive models
only have access to the ones before it I
hope that makes it clearer so the main
idea in excel net is where did where
does this order dependence come
in the autoregressive model the order
dependence actually comes from the
factorization of the sentence of the of
the language model so in a language
model we're actually trying to assess
the probability distribution of
sentences here X is a sentence right and
this can be naturally factorized into a
product over the words where the
probability of each word is only
dependent on the words before it so this
is a this is an equality is not an
approximation this is an equality the
probability of a sequence can be
decomposed into a product of
probabilities like this exactly so this
here is exactly what these auto
regressive models implement each word is
predicted from the words before it right
there are other kinds of autoregressive
models that also do the other direction
where here they say okay the probability
of a sentence is a product and each word
is predicted from the words after it but
it kind of is the same problem you only
ever have access into the one direction
basically however you define the order
of decoding you only ever have access
from a given word to what was before it
in the order so the main idea of excel
net is they say hey why don't we
consider all possible orderings right I
mean that that's kind of a that's it's
an idea so let's go back to our thing
here they say why don't we consider all
possible orderings so basically what we
will do is if this sample comes up New
York is a city all right what I can do
is I can define an ordering let's say I
always want to predict two words so the
bird typically masks out about 15% of
its input to be predicted and here let's
say we'll mask out 20% which
two words so of this sequence will mask
two words and ask the model to predict
it that that will be our our pre
training objective the first time this
sample comes up from the data set
I might specify the order just
classically right just one two three
four five all right I'll predict the
last two words I'll kind of mask them
out right I give the model New York is
and then I could let it predict a and
then in the next step I'll give it New
York is a and let it predict City cool
so now if the pitfall is the word a here
only has access to things before it and
not to city itself City has access to
everything all right so but then I
continue training and the next set time
this sample right it's in my data set
New York is the city the next time it
comes up I simply go for a different
order let's say one two three four five
right so now again I'm asked and asking
to predict the last two tokens which
here our city and York so in the first
step I would give it is a and new and I
will ask it what's here and I'll ask you
to predict city and then in the second
step I'll also give it that and I'll ask
it okay now what's here given all of
that right so new is a city all right
you're asked to predict the missing word
so that that's pretty
so the first step its new is a hmm and
you Resta predicted the second and then
the second step is new is the city and
the rescue protect you first so now as
you can see while predicting City here
all of a sudden we didn't no longer in
this ordering we don't have access to
the world
York so we'll have to learn to predict
City from the rest of the context now
even more even more if we now decide
decide on a different ordering again one
three four five so now well actually
first step is to ask New York City
please predict this thing here all right
yeah you might train the model to
predict is and then the second step you
say New York is City
please predict it now we see before
before when we are at were asked to
predict the word a it only had access to
things to the left of it and the very
first example but now it actually has
access to the entire context so the the
the idea is as we sample this data point
multiple times and each time we decide
on a different ordering duty code for
each the prediction of each token token
sorry will actually have seen many many
parts many different variants of the
context and in expectation will actually
have seen all of the context just like
Bert but will always having have done it
in an order aggressive way so basically
you get all the advantages of being
order aggressive namely that you are
able to decode step by step while always
referring to everything in front of you
in the ordering so the predictions are
not independent but you also get the
benefit of Bert that it's able to
basically look at all of the rest of the
context in expectation in order to make
this prediction so this is this is the
main idea of of excel net they formalize
this jump up again they formalize it in
saying okay what Bert does here is it
actually seek it factorized law
probability of a sentence into this sum
so the product in the law becomes sum
into the sum of log probabilities of no
sorry this is auto regressive
confused ah into the words conditioned
on everything in front of them what bird
does is it actually approximately
factorizes the law of probability into
each word and then everything in the
context everything that's not masked in
the context and this is only an
approximate factorization because you're
basically dropping away all these mask
tokens and um what they do now is they
do the same as the AR as their auto
regressive models here they decompose to
log probability into a sum of log from
abilities over each of the words given
all the words before it but now not
before it in the sequence but before it
in and chosen permutations Z and Z is
sampled uniformly from the set of all
possible permutations so in expectation
they'll see all of the context so this
is the this is the main thing they show
this here in a kind of a picture with so
here is the neural network this is the
input layer then these are the hidden
layers as the attention layers go up and
up here you're asked to predict the the
token so here you're always asked to
predict X 3 so there is no there's never
going to be any awake here since if you
knew X 3 you would be able trivially to
predict X 3 all right so in the in the
first example the factorization order
chosen at random is 3 2 4 1 now you
asked to predict X 3 and we know okay we
should only we should only do this with
things that are before it in the
permutation order well here are since X
3 is the first in the permutation order
we actually don't we don't have anything
to go on
we wait
Stickley asked to predict x3 from
scratch as if it were the start of a
sentence so we'll basically tell the
model I have a sentence that goes
please predict the third right it's a
hard task yeah by the way you're always
able to look at this memory thing here
don't worry about this for now this is
just this is a an augmentation they do
on top of their idea this is not the
core idea so okay but now the second
time this sample comes up from the
training set we decide on a different
order so the order here is 2 4 3 1 now
again we're asked to predict x3 and
we're allowed to look at everything
before it so 2 & 4 as you see here there
are weights from x2 and x4 into this
column that finally is then 8 asked to
predict x3 so this is also this is now
an easier task right you're allowed to
look at the word to the left and to the
right if you have the following
permutation order 1 4 2 3 you're
actually allowed to look at all of the
other words because x3 is at the end of
the permutation order in order to
produce x-ray so all of these four and
the fourth thing is a similar so all of
these four things will appear during
training and you will learn from them so
in expectation C you will basically have
seen all variants of different of
different versions of the context which
which helps a lot apparently right so in
the in order to achieve this they had to
make some architectural changes to the
the model namely what you want to do is
in a single pass through the model here
you not only want to predict one token
but you want to do many predictions this
helps training a lot so vert and
naturally always does like the 15 we
must add 15% of the tokens or so what
was that like 40 50 tokens so it masks
them and it predicts them all at the
same time
now you would like to do this here as
well you would like to predict all at
the same time the ones that you're asked
to predict but of course the problem is
for here if you're asked if in this
factorization order 2 4 3 1 if you're
asked to predict X 3 you're allowed to
look at X 2 and X 4 if you're asked to
predict X 1 you're allowed to look at X
2 X 4 and X 3 so if you only have a
single pass through the model the
question is do you now input X 3 or do
you not because the prediction of X 3 is
not allowed to look at X 3
while the prediction of X 1 is allowed
to look at X 3 so they do an
architectural change in order to achieve
both things so that you can do have a
single pass through the walk through the
model but the prediction of each token
only depends on the things in front of
it in the permutation order and they do
this by having these kind of two stream
is masked to stream attention where they
basically have not only not one hidden
representation like in classic
transformers but they have at each step
two hidden representations one they call
H only called G so the HS are
initialized with the embeddings of the
tokens and the g's are just initialized
randomly and then they get transformed
and the point is the h of the next layer
is always able to look at everything in
front of it including its own its own H
basically it's the one layer down its
own position one layer down while the G
is only allowed to look at the a it's
allowed to look at the ages but the H is
from before right so so all the G's here
are only ever able to look at the H is
from before the current position whereas
the H is always allowed here to look at
the same but also at the H at the
current position
and now at the last layer you simply ask
the model to predict the token from just
the G and you can easily see that this
results in this model only oh yeah only
attending to things before it okay
the G by the way can also look at the G
of the current layer so that's that's
also nothing but it cannot look at that
at the age so there's never any
information flowing from the current
from the current word embedding of the
token you're trying to predict to the
prediction layer so basically that that
means the model can't just look like you
you're not telling the model the answer
yet you're still able to feed to predict
multiple things in a single pass through
the model formally this is described
here in the attention layer so they
divide how they produce the queries and
how they produce the keys and values
usually the queries and the keys and
values are produced from the same hidden
representation but here they produce the
keys and values from the h's in both
cases but to update the G's they produce
the queries from the last layers G and
do produce HS they produce the queries
from the last layer HS and most
importantly when they produce the keys
and values the H is they'll look at here
to update the G you're only allowed to
look at H is before you in the
permutation order but to update the H
you're allowed to look at everything
before including the position you're
currently after so that's kind of the
that's a it's an engineering solution to
the problem introduced by their
augmentation I think it's a pretty
pretty neat solution pretty cool
so the rest of the paper here is
incorporating ideas from transformer
Excel so transformer Excel is one of
these classic transformers that that is
like this AR so this Auto regressive
style of transformer but that has a few
improvements over the classic vanilla
transformer and they incorporate a
number of things here namely first of
all they incorporate this memory thing
so the memory thing allows you to input
longer sequences let's say our our
transformer input length is maximum of
five tokens what the transformer Excel
allows you to do is you input five
tokens and then you save you do your
transformer thing you encode it and they
save something into this memory and then
when you input the next five tokens your
transformer is then allowed to look at
the memory of the last sequence right
and also update it so that that that's
kind of these this memo oxy Sawyer so
you're always allowed to look at these
men blocks from last sequence and then
the hidden representations here of this
sequence they will actually be stored in
the member lok for the next sequence
this is kind of a trick to carry over
information it's not the deep updating
the memory part isn't learned with the
objective to make the next prediction
better but it's just some information
it's a kind of gradient free information
to provide to the next step and it
apparently helps you can incorporate
longer sequences into this transformer
excel so they take this over and
implement this into excel net they also
do relative position encodings relative
segment and codings I won't go into this
too much more here because it's not the
main idea basically so they do
experiments and they
compared to birth architecture with the
same basically same architecture the
same number of parameters and/or the
years and they beat Burt in all of these
kind of NLP tasks or most of I think
they said in 20 they reach new state of
the art in 18 NLP tasks so apparently
their method works very well so what
they do here is a last thing I find
important is an ablation study of the
effects of their improvements so they
wear because kind of my problem is I
never know like they have this new idea
okay we do these random permutations but
then they also say oh and also we
include memory from XL net and we do
relative positioning coatings and so on
to me these kind of papers of course you
reach better numbers you get a new state
of the art so it's kind of a landmark
paper but to me a paper should more be
like a single thing so whatever your
idea is this your idea is these or
drinks and whatever you need to do to
make that work okay fine but then why
why the additional transformer Excel
things it's it's really then hard to
estimate how much of the improvement
comes from your ID and how much of the
improvement simply comes from the fact
that you already put these other things
actually have nothing to do with it so I
appreciate these kind of analyses called
ablation studies where they kind of try
to take away the memory and these things
and kind of look at what it's doing to
the model and use you see here kind of
degrades down here as for example this
con degrades as you take stuff away
while still being more kind of more
successful than Burt so that that I
would say also yeah here is more unclear
but also kind of seems to degrade a bit
and while being more successful than
Bert I appreciate this there's some and
of really trying to show that your gains
really come from your new idea and not
from some other stuff all right so the
last thing I want to mention actually is
this thing so someone claiming or
calculating that it costs two hundred
and forty five thousand dollars to train
the Excel net model the way they
describe it in the paper I'm sure that's
gonna be brought down because it was
brought down that like the time the
train was brought down with Bert as well
but this is just I mean this is crazy
this is just training it um it it kind
of gives large questions about the state
of research and the ability for kind of
let's say more academic players to
participate in research on the one hand
of course we like of course these
companies should be able to do this and
on the other hand if it seems like
currently in some fields just putting
more money on the table will get you a
better result not this this actually
like this paper is actually a cool idea
but it's still kind of primitively
expensive to even reproduce it yeah
right so that was that was that for this
paper I hope you enjoyed this and see ya